foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing but bad news for the Iowa
stallions what an idiot
Mr kovich I will offer you community
service coaching adults with
intellectual disabilities your honor we
talking
no boo-boo words okay fellas we're gonna
do a simple ball handling exercise my
girlfriend loves this
it's impossible to coach these guys you
don't have to turn them into the Lakers
they just need to feel like a team
uh we're gonna need some help you're
getting a player off the injured list
welcome to the team cosentina what's
with the boogie board you do you lie to
me okay where do you got this guy he
just showed up one day
listen to my sister Alex don't do a
couple karaoke with us
yeah and now you gotta keep me down
ain't better than anybody you got
you got it yeah you can tell hey we got
next Don't make me say it make you say
what
that's a boo-boo word we got nice coach
this doesn't feel right
I should be coaching in the NBA well you
never know where things could lead
no doubt
you can get this team to the Special
Olympics finals
you might be ready to be back in the NBA
we've been following your incredible
story coach Marcus is just one win away
from qualifying for the regional
tournament I don't know if you're brave
or crazy
I know this is your shot at being
champions
girlfriend problems that was fun you
were passable I don't have a girlfriend
make sense oh what am I that bad looking
you know McConaughey
[Music]